such a special occasion you're
performing tonight what does it mean to
you is there like an extra special 'no
stew it is just certain things in my
life in my career that you just do you
know certain things that just feel right
[Music]
there's my second time coming back here
and this is one of those things it just
feels right and anytime you see all
these great artists come together you
know I mean it's you know people people
come together for a reason you know what
I mean and this is a great one I was
talking to Anthony Russo earlier he said
he's joining you on stage tonight and he
talked about all the advice that you've
been giving him being on tour with him I
learned a lot of just about like touring
and how that all works which is a huge
part of success for any artist so I
think I probably learned most of my
stuff from that and then just like work
at the Expedia time and how all that
kind of like manifests in the music good
music and something I learned as well
what is it like to kind of take on that
mentor role I love it man that's my
little brother and I see you know I see
a lot of him like you know I remember
the first time I met him I think you
could tell a lot about a person
sometimes just by that initial
interaction you know the energy they
give off and the first time I heard his
voice on a song I was just blown away
like you know yes I'm really special so
shout out to Anthony Russo man I'm
excited for everything that's to come
for him I'm also excited for everything
that's to come for you I saw pictures of
you in the studio today on Instagram
what's going on yeah I mean I can never
stay away for too long I was so ready to
finally come home I was on tour almost
nine months it was like a long cycle but
you know we finally got home and you
know I try to do the normal guy thing
the just live in my house it would be
normal it's not really it's not really
my thing I would take a break
[Music]
I have to talk to you about Halsey any
chance that we're gonna see you guys
another collaboration we're so excited
that you're back together yeah who knows
you know she just put out her single
that's doing incredible right now so I'm
really happy for her
what was behind that cute birthday
Instagram that you wrote for her you
called her your queen just speaking from
the heart you know I think the world of
her she's a really special person a
really special human being
besides you know how great of an artist
she is but you know anything human I
love her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]